[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google
Kubernetes Engine,
or GKE's, node
auto-upgrades feature
helps to keep your
cluster nodes up
to date with the cluster
control plane version
whenever the control
plane is updated.
Node auto-upgrades
provide several benefits--
lower management overhead.
With this, you don't need to
manually update the nodes when
the control plane is upgraded.
Better security--
with this feature, GKE
ensures that the security
updates are automatically
applied.
Ease of use--
provide a simple way
to keep your nodes up to date
with the latest Kubernetes
features.
In this video, we will cover how
to configure node auto-upgrades
in GKE.
If you are running
a GKE cluster,
the two most common
ways to configure it
are either by using Google Cloud
console or Google Cloud CLI.
First, we will learn how to
enable node auto-upgrades
for an existing node for
use in Google Cloud Console.
In the Google Cloud Console,
go to Kubernetes Engine page.
In the cluster list, select the
cluster you want to configure.
Click the Nodes tab.
Then, click the node
pool for which you
want to enable auto-upgrade.
On the Node Pool Details
page, click Edit.
Under the Management
section, select
the Enable
Audo-Upgrade checkbox.
Click Save.
Wait for confirmation
notification.
There you go.
You have successfully enabled
node pools to be auto-upgraded.
Now, let's learn how to
enable node auto-upgrades
using Google Cloud CLI.
We will use Cloud
Shell in this example.
Before running the
Google Cloud CLI,
ensures that you have the
following information--
notebook, name, your
cluster name, and the zone
where the node pool is located.
Run the following command.
Finally, you can verify
that your node pools have
auto-upgrade enabled by using
G-cloud DESCRIBE command
as follows.
Congratulations.
You have successfully enabled
node pools to be auto-upgraded.
One last note-- clusters
enrolled to our release
channels can also be upgraded.
In this scenario, auto-upgrade
is enabled by default
and cannot be disabled.
Finally, if you are running
a GKE Autopilot cluster,
node auto-upgrades are enabled
by default and cannot be
overridden.
Check out the documentation for
more information on GKE node
auto-upgrades.
[MUSIC PLAYING]